تستعر المعارك في الشرق الاوكراني بعد
تعزيزات موسكو العسكريه لمحور دانيت الذي
شهد تقدما للقوات الروسيه في ظل انتقادات
مؤسس مجموعه فاجنر القتاليه لمسار المعارك
التي تديرها الدفاع في محاور عديده ذلك
بعد ان حقق مقاتلوا فاغنر نجاحا املموسا
شمال المقاطعه في مدينه باخموت برا
ول مثل مجموعه اخرى من المقاتلين
الاوكرانيين الى ديارهم والذين قاتلوا
بشجاعه ثم قتلوا وزير الدفاع الروسي
ظهر فجاه في ميدان معارك دانيت كرد منه
على اتهامات بريجوجن الذي قال ان الضباط
الروس لا يعرفون شيئا عن مجرى المعارك
واوضاع الجنود مطالبا بتحميلهم مسؤوليه
الاخطاء
ننتظر منكم انجازات جديده وننتظر تحقيق
اهداف الخطط التي وضعناها لان جهدنا هام
جدا لوطننا
رصات العديده التي تشهدها العمليه
العسكريه الروسيه الا ان تنافسا كبيرا
انطلق بين القاده من اجل تقديم انجازات
ملموسه لسيد الكريند انعكس نقصد دخيره
والسلاح عند القوات الاوكرانيه خلال
الاسابيع الماضيه على مسار المعارك في
العمليه العسكريه ذلك ما ادى الى انخفاض
وتيره القصف الاوكراني على مناطق
الانفصاليين في دمباس لقناتي العربيه
والحدث رائد الاغبر